yo ho yo ho a pirate's life for me  perhaps cuz we get to be pirates again  yep you always did like this world still  it's a real shame we don't have a bigger  ship  [Music]  [Music]  [Music]  yes  [Music]  you back in the organization yes  surprising isn't it Jack don't you give  this creep the time of day  Sora sander it's the count mustn't  strike a pirate's aboard ship when said  pirate offers to confabulate I am  looking for a box arendelle is safer  with me staying up here oh please go  away  [Music]  then the Unversed collected enough  screams and sadness from those children  yeah time they were trashing our company  in the process you're following her  maybe she's one of the seven pure lights  we need the news seven hearts No set  your heart free and at the end you'll  finally realize what destiny has in  store for you in fact your reward might  be right around the corner hey axel  Hey Viking the love got your hair too  [Music]  you